Israel's waren Gaza has
intensified and most of its victims are
women and
children hospitals which are still
standing can only provide first aid and
that too is running
out overnight more strikes on besieged
Northern G
hundreds more killed
inalia and even sanun in more isra
attacks there is no electricity or fuel
or medicine
here stairwells are
Rubble living rooms have caved in from
the top you can see Neighbors are also
pulling out the dead and
wounded she says the house came down on
their head
while they were
sleeping Medics and First Responders are
also being targeted in Northern Gaza
these civil defense workers say they'
have lost three people in as many
attacks in the last 24
hours it's direct targeting of civil
defense workers with drones it happens
while we work to evacuate people buried
under the rubble in P
here Kamal adwan hospital is on its last
supplies the Indonesian Hospital
surrounded by Israeli tanks has been
given a few hours to
evacuate at least 30 vehicles in
coordination with the World Health
Organization have already evacuated
hundreds of
patients but Medics say evacuating
patients from the Intensive Care Unit or
those who are critical will kill them in
the process gaza's largest al-shifa
hospital has faced more threats the
director has been arrested by
intelligence
Services the World Health Organization
has not yet sent us any report to
explain the situation including the
numbers and names of those detained the
inability to contact alifa means we
don't know who has been arrested we are
waiting for a report from The Who
because there's a chance some of those
detainees will be killed we know the
occupation forces are capable of that
the Ministry of Health has decided to
stop all coordin with the who regarding
the evacuation until they send us a
report explaining what
happened but hospitals Remain the target
for Israel even if they've run out of
everything to provide urgent care for
more than 30,000 people who've been
wounded in Israel's war on
Gaza jaid
aler make sure to subscribe to our
channel to get the latest news from Al
jazer
now